the day started with hope their mission
emblazoned for all to see to feed a
Raqib hasn't felt the air on her face
for eight months that ended today at an
airport in East London as her journey to
a specialist hospital in Italy began for
her mother chelina who has barely left
her side it was an anxious morning I had
a really tough morning this morning
forget the trust actually banned all my
family members from seeing to feed her
this morning so no one was actually
allowed in and she was actually whisked
away while everyone was actually waiting
outside some really emotional at the
moment their departure marked a first
never before has a family who fought the
NHS in court to keep their child alive
been able to successfully move them
abroad on an earlier flight to Genoa her
father Mohammed waited with excitement
and with nerves they have quite a
facility of rehabilitating her
that was something what I will look
forward to what's the dream dream is for
her to go home to feed a suffered
catastrophic brain damage in February
when blood vessels in her brain ruptured
her British doctors believed withdrawing
life support was in her best interests
her parents fought them in court and won
she'll now call the gasoline II
Children's Hospital her home while
doctors here agree she can't be cured
they hope a breathing tube will help her
live without a ventilator to feed as
parents have described coming here as a
turning point for their family
they've always argued that she'd be
safer here in Italy and that's because
while the UK system prioritizes a
patient's best interest
the Italian system puts more emphasis on
the sanctity of life here when there's
uncertainty over prognosis patients are
given time lots of people in the UK
think that this journey that defeat is
taking is undignified and maybe even
cruel do you think it's right that she's
going to be kept alive in this condition
for maybe 20 years not a peltro it's not
much of time no one knows how long it
could be we will offer the little girl
and her family the opportunity to make
well informed choices including
recognising in the moment when
conditions cannot assure quality of life
anymore dignity and quality of life are
the crucial factors she arrived in Genoa
after nightfall met by police and local
dignitaries
her parents overwhelming relief
self-evident later with two Fida settled
it was starting to sink in I'm emotional
that have left my family behind
particularly my son but the same from
the joy the taffeta is actually act of
Bart's and in here in Kathleen II where
doctors will believe in her believing
her improvement that is a very very key
important issue for us well some will
question what precedent this case sets
one family are just delighted their
child is being allowed to fight on Helen
Anne Smith in Genoa Italy